little Blanca just Blanca just vodka
yes I'll leave the last name Blanca
little Blanca humor so Blanca the good
news is I did with some doing get you
approved to fight in the second street
fighter tournament yeah congratulations
great unfortunately I did have to add a
couple new clauses regarding travel on
the grounds that you are a terrifying
monster so once we get that who's that
you can't fly in airplanes because you
are a terrifying monster oh I'm not a
monster see I I am human hmm I was just
raised in the jungle and then when I was
a child I was exposed to some electric
eels werewolf was born human to then
vampires were born human Frankenstein
was a bunch of humans yeah so basically
what you're just saying is only making
me believe that you are indeed a monster
but not a monster mm-hmm
listen you are a monster and as such all
contestants with talent appendage that
means you're terrifying claw hands while
in transit must relegate to a freight
status cubed wall door linked enclosure
you're gonna have to fly in a crate
underneath the plane I'm not flying in a
crate underneath you're gonna have to
fly in a crate underneath the plane see
Vega told me that all of his flights
were business class yeah it's not me
it's the TSA I mean they're very
uncomfortable with people not taking
their shoes off I'm convention if we
send human with the shackles that don't
come off that's gonna go beep beep beep
beep you can search the shackle sir that
doesn't make me any more comfortable
putting you in a middle seat on a
seven-hour flight to Russia to flight
Zangief I mean between a nun and a baby
there's no way you're not gonna eat that
baby I mean look at me and tell me
you're not gonna eat that smoking not
good eat the small baby keep eye contact
while you do it
I'm not gonna eat the small baby still
looked away that makes me think you're
definitely gonna eat the small baby I'll
give a piece of baby stuck in your
throat
no I'm insulted
I am insulted by your inference if you'd
like to talk to our HR department I can
gather them into a small Posse burn some
torches and come to where you live ah
this is [ __ ] Munster I walk upright
I speak English learn the language gets
you close to the children so you can
scoop them up and eat them okay
I don't eat children and I'd appreciate
you not inferring it to be more of like
uh who killed all our goats and then we
pan over and you're just covered in
blood I don't even eat meat I'm mostly
vegetarian Munster ah
human monster I am NOT a monster you are
a monster I'm a human you look like the
bastard child of carrot top and the Hulk
I don't have to listen to this
you look like Bob Marley merged with a
bar of Irish Spring soap that is
slanderous sir what's your favorite
energy drink it's not Red Bull is it
does it look like you scratched the
front all right you know what enough of
this enough I am a human I am NOT a
monster I am here to fight in a
tournament how do I make that happen
easy you just have to fill out form 7b
so I'm here here and here permission to
treat you as cargo fine I will concede
your foolish demands and over here
you'll see three choices for your
in-flight meal dry food wet food or dry
food mixed with wet food I'll just go
ahead and check mixed every good boy
likes the mill I don't have to listen to
this anymore sir good day up bunky you
didn't fill in your address should I put
underneath my daughter's bed are you
still living in a black lagoon mud start